[Musica]
si toglie musica bene porca vacca da
latte di ragazzi come vede questo nuovo
io sono fan j oggi siamo sud world is
the game
l'unica roba reggae che sono in una
location un po improvvisata perché mi
devo a bruciare anche ogni tanto quindi
ho deciso di prendere questa vacanza una
non vacanza registrando anche in vacanza
come c'erano un miliardo di impulsivo il
game ne erano usciti veramente un sacco
hanno deciso di fare the world is east
game per essere controcorrente non
andiamo a fare il gioco più facile del
mondo
comunque sia ragazzi anche se questo
gioco più facile del mondo io devo
tradurre perché solo in inglese vi devo
tradurre anche quello che c'è scritto
quindi non è proprio semplice perché
sapete che il mio inglese è molto molto
scissi benvenuto al world is his game la
tua reputazione come un individuo
intelligente ti precede come me ai nove
vite soltanto nota per il tempo va verso
produrre meglio di così pronto next ha
già poi già partiti va bene numeri te
come sto sfigato guarda bene qual è il
paese più grande musica del cazzo non
otteniamo faber il paese più grande di
una di sense correct g piace anche tipo
col sombrero avevo prima 123456 qual è
il numero seguente giorgio nord sempre
magari non solo un obbedite macchie ha
mancato anche il tasto perché questo è
difficile
il papa è cattolico ma che cazzo si è
messa parete domande mi spiega dei
problemi a il papa è cattolico come io
sono un maria ceo quindi si corre che è
stato è questo che cosa sto ragazzo ne
so io
beh non lo so ora che ho sparato non
sono non sono statunitense non mi sono
queste cose sono messicano io ero
incinta di ragazzo perché il cappello ai
cinque caramelle e in un contenitore e
nei tiri fuori 3
quante caramelle ai due il corecom in
cui ha sempre 5 perché chi se ne frega
vede tiro fuori per sempre
cos'è che metti nel tostapane a devo
scrivere proprio il penne no a tu non lo
fai
ok ma perché ci sono persone che lo
fanno qualche problema che è stato e
questo e allora si continui a farmi
domande di geografia sugli stati di dio
che cosa strana miccia adesso hai da wow
clicca il bottone io giuro che domani
esco per strada investo tutti i gatti e
trova mentre katy strascichi come miley
cyrus corre a quante domande ha risposto
fino adesso cosa minchia ne so io in
corso aver sparato lo posso sapere
bhatti mia tris a per questo sito se mi
chiedi di batterti l'attrice magari sì
[Musica]
okaka be my pari ma la fattura era pari
al meno pari sei sicuro no ben questo
l'ho cercata qual è la capitale di new
york albania o new york city albania
questa sapevo qual è il tuo colore
preferito ce ne so come fai beni penney
ha preso spara al al boss
questo sicuramente non è un boss a
questo e bosco giocato un sacco io call
of duty il triangolo è solo ma prima di
fare domande sul triangolo adesso il
triangolo no ragazzi son riuscito a
perdere facciamo un altro tentativo
stavolta un po più serio era solo per
capire più o meno come la sto gioco però
è simpatico tranne il gatto e simpatico
play
dai facciamo la serie stavolta quanti
dalmata ci sono bei ragazzi giochiamo ha
detto il centro uno sparo neanche ho
contato neanche o contatto parola di
quattro lettere un pilot amante e
giacche ho saputo tradurre piro manta in
inglese dove sono le donne deve sapere
come il fuoco funzione
aspetta 10 secondi perché perché questo
gioco mi deve far perdere la mia vita
perché perché
quanto fa due più due la mia piccola
cosa ha sbagliato a produrre il
significato era cosa succede se mette
vicino 22 ed era 22 non 4 però vabbè
quanti caps qassem caps 2 googlare
scusate artax a quante quante tasse in
un quarto che cazzo vuol dire ragalano
capitolo 14
non lo so dire quante tasse iniqua 4
correct che curlo a caso quanti quarti
in un gallone quanto fottutamente è un
gallone melai dragoni piglette per il
culo ma che ne so
4 sempre 4 caso 4 michiara che la
risposta e 44 e tipo tu vivi nell'aria
sempre guarda quanto fa due più due
444 neanche leggono leggo più 4 esposte
4 mag a tu vivi nell'aria quanto i lati
a un rettangolo 4 quante gambe quattro
hanno tarato 44 anni di merda quante
stagioni nell'anno 4 mar mi prendi per
il culo quanti quante dita su una mano
volevi testa dico lo sapevo che mi
faceva scherzi
ora che assieme a 30 domande giuste
palab attimi at risk minchia questo è
stato aria prima è stata difficile
ripartiamo 123 e melo su chi cosa metti
nel tostapane toast stavolta la zecca ma
come è la vita mia
cosa vecchia e tostapane tua nonna
risolvi l'equazione per l'aics ma cosa
fermi che quando vorrei evocare a
matematica delle medie dirà il 6 che
diventa positivo quindi 12 più 6 fa 18
18 diviso due fa 9
[Musica]
alle medie regala matematica delle medie
so fare solo questo però non solamente
cammini in un ristorante nella stanza ci
sono dieci persone che hanno 21 anni tre
persone che hanno 26 anni sette persone
che hanno 29 anni nove persone che non
31 17 sono uomini quante personesono nel
ristorante 10 più 13 più 7 fa 20 20 ti
deve morire tutta la stirpe e niente
oppure perso no vabbè dai ragazzi era
molto più semplice the world game almeno
in questo video avete visto un po di
quoziente intellettivo pero che il mio
sombrero sia di vostro gradimento
soprattutto la cosa che volevo farvi
sapere che se vi sembrano aiuti in
matematica scrivetemi pure in direct ci
penso io
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
ha conosciuto subito bisogno di un
momento non mi piace sempre ti schieri
ci vediamo al prossimo video e finiamo
col sombrero che fa più figo da ragazzi
[Musica]